let's give it up for daughtry's lead
singer chris
[Music]
hey what's up man your beard game is on
point
[Laughter]
thank you so much good to see you oh my
god you guys are having way too much fun
there i wish i was there
i know i might have had too much matcha
i don't have a lot of caffeine
so something's happening i got my i got
my coffee here it's
it's my drug of choice this is my
lifeline i love it how have you been
yeah i'm awesome i'm
honestly like life is so good um i miss
being on the road
but i'm also really loving this
this home life i haven't been home this
long in 15 years so
yeah um it's cool i get to be on your
show and at home at the same time
i know it's like says every musician in
the world for the last year and a half
like every
everybody was like wait what what do we
do like because we're all used to it
yeah agreed well your new song is called
heavy as the crown so what's it about
uh you know i think i was thinking about
it today i was like we're we're all kind
of like
the stars of our own movie you know what
i mean like we're all our
all the leads in our own film and our
where we are
the kings and queens of our own castle
um
and life has so much like there's so
much pressure
on it just to live uh especially these
days and
um not only that but the pressures of
carving your own path without conforming
to
what everyone else thinks is normal and
um
yeah uh just the daily choices that we
have to make
it's a lot of pressure sometimes and uh
i guess you can kind of sum it up that
way
yeah i mean god that was nicely done i
feel a little sad but that's okay
um performing because i love i love the
message i love that it's deep and i
think a lot of people are late
especially for this past year and a half
everybody you know heavy isn't crowded
you feel if you're responsible for your
family if you're responsible for
there's a lot going on financial crisis
mental health is an issue right now
people lost their jobs like it's a lot
going on so
um it's you know probably good to have a
song that you know comes out and people
relate to
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever